we need to talk about what really
matters and what really matters is that
a truck carrying a hundred lab monkeys
crashed some lady tried petting the
monkey and now she's got covered
symptoms
correlation is not causation oh this is
a hard segue off of the media into
something much more fun yes and
potentially apocalyptic so uh this is
the story you guys may have heard that a
truck crashed in like near Scranton and
a hundred monkeys were on lab monkeys
the monkeys are in high demand right now
because they're doing coveted research
on them I guess it's what they're
reporting The Daily Mail so a couple of
the monkeys escaped some lady gets out
of her car if the truck crashes she
steps a monkey poop walks over to one of
the cages it's busted open apparently
and tries to pet the monkeys thinking
she wanted rabies what happened next so
yeah all right she's now sick with what
she describes as coven symptoms
she's saying she's got she's got coveted
symptoms she called it a day from hell
she's being quarantined apparently they
sent letters out to law enforcement who
responded saying you've got a quarantine
for like 31 days because there's like
monkey diseases you could get and
they're also isolating the monkeys to
figure out if they got diseases
everybody's tweeting at me you know
Planet of the Apes 12 Monkeys and the
movie outbreak because they're like this
is how it happens so uh you know I think
it's funny that we can joke about it be
like haha the monkey truck crashed and
the lady got sick and it's just like you
know what if within like a month there's
like you know 300 confirmed cases of
monkey monkey covet or whatever and then
we're like oh you know just 300 people
in that area they've quarantined it and
like a year later it's like coveted you
know covid 20 monkey syndrome is like
going crazy what would you name the
monkey variant like the monkey variant
that's what you'd call it bro you just
did it call it the monkey variant I have
to point out that this happened in my
home state of Pennsylvania uh up on I-80
in the middle of nowhere that this lady
was driving along and saw the crash
and like do not approach do not feed the
animals like do not congratulate let me
show you my my tweeted holy-ish it's
happening someone uh this guy Nico
responded with just a picture of Alex
Jones leaning back with his hands in
front of his mouth yeah taking a deep
breath but um I'm gonna I'm gonna say
this as a mostly as a joke but also just
as an idea this story is a little on the
nose it's like
it's a lottery ticket in my opinion that
a monkey truck crashes they're lab
monkeys and a woman just happened to be
following it gets out decides to to
touch them try and touch the monkeys
they hiss at her she gets sick and I'm
like this is the perfect narrative for
the start of a new variant you know what
I mean we're just checking the Box we're
just checking the boxes here I mean this
is I I still can't believe that this is
real here's the crazy funny things to me
is that there's a hundred exactly 100
monkeys on the train which I maybe isn't
that weird to people but especially if
it's like lab research that they yeah
they wouldn't have like some why not 99
62 why not 101. people love those
they're so weird well I mean you know
100 years
but here's the crazy thing right so when
we were researching this story yes
indeed I was like let's let's try and
pull up this article and so I was
looking at all these stories none of
them mentioned the woman is saying she
has coveted symptoms except her on her
Facebook post in the Daily Mail Daily
Mail got it when you pull up all of
these stories on Google Google they all
just say she's got pink eye she's got
she's got a pink eye that's it and then
you take a look at the what she actually
posted on Facebook and she says the
symptoms are covered symptoms like
seriously a day from hell
that's what she said
why is the media not reporting that she
has coveted symptoms don't they like the
fear don't they want the fear yeah it
exactly right and
and what's to say it's not covid but the
idea that she said it and put it out
there and they don't want anything to do
with it
I I mean it's pretty pathetic that
you're willing to stoop down to you know
you would think when you're putting
together a news story about this
Insanity you would think that you would
want a post like a Facebook post where
it's a good paragraph of her retelling
of what happened you would think that
you would want to include that in your
news reports but there why are they
downplaying it that's that's what I
understand she said covet symptoms and
we pulled up all these other stories and
it's like pink eye she has she has pink
eye exactly they don't want to talk
about maybe they're afraid that there's
gonna be like she has cover symptoms and
then she'll turn around to be like
actually it turned out I just had the
cold in the book oh but there's Colbert
systems but it was a culture I think
they I I don't know what to think to be
completely honest this one's weird to me
you the media would love to push a
coveted scare narrative I mean they they
get they make money on it yeah the
permanent lockdowns they have continuous
stories day after day of people in
hospitals people dying and it and it's
very sad I I understand that and these
are people's loved ones however yeah it
is pure fear porn it's it's actual death
if they're not they're not pushing it
and they're not and they're not pushing
it whereas previously with Russia it was
this fear of something that really
wasn't attached to people's lives but
now they have something that you know
saying if you don't do as we say you'll
die right with the covet stuff you mean
yeah whereas versus other people in her
Facebook posts she specifically says
symptoms are covet systems she said uh
I'm very low risk for I don't know what
yet but symptoms are coveted symptoms I
think that part of the problem here is
that the media is this is a narrative
they can't control I think that's the
reason that we can't find her
um Facebook post anywhere except the
Daily Mail I think that they're trying
to get a hold of the story and try to
see how they can spin it I think it's
too early for them to really have their
actual narrative lined up perfectly yet
and I think yeah if and it turns out to
to not have been covered though I would
guarantee you they would backtrack and
put it up and saying you know she
thought she you know Fallon thought she
had coveted symptoms right yeah but she
ended up not is she is she maybe saying
something else like what what could that
possibly mean other than you know like
that's that's the story she's saying
that she's got sick they say uh in the
title that she has a cough and pink eye
and then her Facebook post says symptoms
are coveted symptoms saying that a cough
is Coveted symptoms is a little like no
no no no no no they're saying when she
said symptoms are covered systems
symptoms they said they're saying it's a
cough she literally in the Facebook post
they put from her it says coveted
symptoms but like if you look at these
Omicron coveted symptoms I saw five of
them it's like runny nose fever fatigue
you're like okay those are also cold
symptoms so if she goes out and they go
out and she says they made she might
have covered she has covetism it turns
out she has a common cold people be like
uh but she did have coveted symptoms
like so maybe maybe
when you see that in China now there was
a report I saw uh from one of the
networks this morning they reported that
in China now if you go into a drugstore
and you buy
cough medicine like Tylenol and the
government will flag you and say that
you have to go get covet tested wow that
they noticed that if you went into a
drugstore and bought and you went to the
aisle and bought these specific
medicines that everybody goes to a CVS
or Walgreens nowadays to get uh you know
Tylenol you know ibuprofen or cough
syrup
the government will flag you and say you
need to go get coveted tested because
you're buying these medications for
symptoms that line up with covid I mean
it's one way to inflate the cases but
we're but you know we're going to send
our athletes into this yeah I don't I
don't know you know what will end up
happening with the story I I kind of
feel like nothing it's it's like the
monkeys escaped I think they killed them
they captured a couple and then killed
one of them like the reporters that the
monkey was seen in a tree and then
several shots rang out yeah you know
people didn't watch what happened but
you know it's like when they yeah yeah
it's like when you're like watching a
movie and they take the animal off
camera and then you have bangs it's
implied
but I just wanna I just want to point
out take a look at this picture right
here look at look look at homeboy one of
the monkeys pictured was found in a tree
and three shots were later heard WNEP
reported yeah imagine being this dude
right and you're you're you're you're
you're born or bred or captured by these
you know giant creatures who are poking
you and prodding you and injecting you
with stuff and then the the ship they're
on crashes and you get out and you're
hiding doing just like terrified and
desperate and they see you and they just
kill you imagine if you were like born
into a country and the social media
networks were experimenting on you and
your government was experimenting on you
and then you tried to escape
North Korea I'm talking about the United
States you can escape the United States
you can kind of Escape you can't escape
the system though that they don't want
you off the grid yeah man we're we're so
you know my thing is like I feel bad for
this dude look at him man he's chilling
he's not doing anything look at us he's
probably scared he's probably I guess
want to be left alone so monkeys do like
yes you see they climb the trees and
they're just chilling out they're living
they're trying to live their best lives
here yeah that's brutal were these
monkeys infected with something
beforehand did it ever come out or was
it or they have their way to get tested
honestly they haven't said yet
um what the article from The Daily Mail
says is that monkeys are in high demand
for coveted research to do experiments
on them and that it's also true that
monkeys can carry herpes B which if
infects a person they get you know brain
swelling and then die yeah the herpes B
virus it's extremely rare but it can
kill you if you don't get treated for it
and I think there's only been ever one
case of it transmitting from person to
person so it's like not that good at
infecting humans but that's why they're
scared about these monkeys I just feel
bad for the monkey bro who's like I am
finally free and then he like climbs the
tree and he's like looking around and
then you shoot him it's like uh spoiler
alert like Harrison Bergeron man that
monkey had a Harrison Bergeron moment
out under the freedom and tasted it for
a moment
they do I believe I believe no I thought
it just ended uh it ends with like have
you ever getting kicked open and a bunch
of people screaming and really I'm
pretty sure yeah no I thought I read it
I thought it was a short story I'm
pretty sure I'll look it up I'm curious
yeah I think you're thinking of
something else maybe I'm wrong I
remember that not turning out so well
for Harrison comparison
but yes shout out to uh rural pa uh
Danville PA is where it took place uh
great people in central Pennsylvania but
uh I don't know I would not want to be
living near there right now but that's
just me
I wonder what they were doing with these
guys these monkeys you know oh
definitely taking them to test on them
for sure yeah yeah but like were they
doing covered research
imagine yeah one of the senator asking
fauci about this the next day uh Dr
Falcon 100 monkeys well you know fauci
runs at Monkey Island okay I gotta
that's a little hyperbock fauci funded
through the niaid this uh um Monkey
Island thing they basically breed a
bunch of monkeys in captivity to do
torture like to do to experiment on
maximum pain yeah and they call it
that's being called back to this maximum
pain experiments where they take the
monkeys and try and make them feel as
much pain as possible to see what they
can tolerate before like passing out or
whatever yo fauci's got a track record
for doing real messed up stuff yeah and
that and speaking of Tucker earlier
that's been something he's really been
talking a lot about he's had people from
peed on what did you expect someone Peta
being on Fox News I think Pete is trash
that's true when someone um becomes
science you know it's it's no longer
ethical uh when the ethics are out the
window it's science first ethics second
like fauces actually declared he was the
science what a strange thing for a human
to declare that's like Nazi scientists
man they would put the science first the
ethics came second
um experimenting on a populace within a
rushed vaccine is like I get it in an
emergency you maybe there's precedent
but man it is still an experimentation
well for uh I think we were talking who
were we talking to
um I think maybe maybe it was badia
Hunger Sargon the the vaccines that came
out for you know with operation warp
speed went through the clinical trials
with people who volunteered for it and
even the right was was very critical of
parents who were offering up their kids
to volunteer for the trials and stuff
like that so they went through their
basic trials and then we we had a
discussion about the Nuremberg code
because people were saying that they're
still doing long-term testing which is
happening now because typically it takes
like a long time
but by that standard if that's
experiment experimental everything is
because they're they're constantly
rolling out new treatments that they're
then you know collecting data for
long-term studies yeah it's really like
only the Tuskegee experiment the things
we hear about after effect when things
have gone wrong is when we really can
look at it and say well that was a bad
experiment which if you recall Joe Biden
confused Tuskegee Airmen with the
Tuskegee experiment uh he talked about
why African-Americans are getting
vaccinated he would refer to oh what
happened to the Tuskegee Airmen is a
barrier for African-Americans to get
vaccinated this is this this stuff is
this stuff is draining I know it's
draining it's impressive that it's we
talk about it every night think about
that daily when you guys are talking
about examples inside the United States
you go to China what the Soviets were
doing yes not in Nazi Germany uh that
that stuff the depravity there you wanna
you wanna you wanna talk about honesty
and things that people never want to
talk about uh how much have humans how
much of Americans back benefited from
the human experimentation of the Nazis
and the Japanese yeah a great deal the
that horrifying unit in Japan they would
731 one of the stories I read is that
they took people and they would like
stick their arms out into Sub-Zero
temperatures to watch what would happen
to a person who was in between and then
they would like shatter the arm once it
froze to see what would happen and
because of that psychotic research we
were able to save tons of lives when it
comes to frostbite wow yeah it's
horrifying yeah you know people people
people need to have a dose of reality
these monkey experiments are horrifying
the Beagle experiments are horrifying
but we don't sometimes we don't know
what we're gonna find when we do stupid
things when we do crazy things so so you
know my thing is like I'm not going to
be naive
and just outright be like we should ban
all of this stuff because I'm like
we do animal testing for medications
before we put it on humans because we
don't want humans to die and it sucks
that animals die in the experimentation
but what's the alternative don't have
medical advancement don't do trials
don't do experimentation I just looked
up what has medicine learned from the
Nazis this is from the guardian in the
first sentences a lot
including X-rays I mean it just goes on
and on and on how are we supposed to uh
Advance Medical Technology if we don't
do like experiment on ourselves I mean
yeah true that's so so history of
medicine horrible right to try
legislation I think is is a huge huge
opportunity in that you've got people
who have nothing left to lose who are
like yo I'm dying I need something let
me try this experimental medication
because I got nothing left to lose I'm
like that I think Florida recently
signed that legislation around a
scientist yeah that's that's good Trump
was very much in favor of this I think
too yeah uh before the show we were
talking about this gentleman who got uh
the heart transplanted from a pig which
is it's really interesting because they
did a deep dive on him after the fact
they were like oh my gosh this guy had
committed a bunch of terrible crimes and
I was like it makes sense to me that
they would experiment with this weird
heart on a guy who had committed crimes
it sounds terrible to say but then we
got to talking about this Unit 731 I was
like this is terrible but this is where
we are this is how we've learned a lot
of the things we've learned it was a the
news cycle on this has been fascinating
because the Washington Post had this
glowing story because it happened up in
Baltimore
and
um and then it was probably maybe three
days later it came out it was a story
right on the front page and the whole
thing is deconstructing what happened
that this guy was in a fight I think in
Hagerstown got in a bar fight with
somebody who uh was feeling up his wife
and he stabbed him and left him
paralyzed and he served years in prison
and so he was a you know thing for this
and the entire piece is because he's
still in the hospital and he's not
really able to do interviews needless to
say so his poor son has been left to
have to talk about this and like what do
you have to say about this you know does
your Dad really deserve basically the
post trying to argue does your Dad
really deserve life and this quiet and
it's a it's a really sad question here
but
um obviously doctors are going to look
really good if this ends up working
I think if people uh
I I think I you know I understand why
there's certain people who want to keep
the populace in the dark on a lot of
issues
because I think regular people don't
want to acknowledge the great benefits
they get they're really awful things
that Anthony fauci has uh authorized
have have I I don't know to what extent
they've benefited us but it's it's not
so much about what he specifically has
done I think the gain of function stuff
has kind of screwed us substantially but
in general
if the American people
actually got an honest assessment of
everything they've gained in exchange
for the pain and suffering caused by a
lot of research and War I really wonder
what this country would be like because
I remember saying this during
um
20 like 2015 when Hillary was running
and I would tell my friends
and I'd be like
do you like the way you live do you like
your your you know your wealth American
you know Empire do you like traveling
the world and having whatever you want
I'll vote for Hillary Clinton because
she's going to maintain the status quo
of the the global Elites in the in the
war the bombings Syria all that stuff
and you're going to benefit from it do
you want to you know and that stuff do
you want to try and pull it back do you
want to focus on this country and over
Donald Trump but a lot of people didn't
want to have that conversation they
don't want to acknowledge that the
United States benefits greatly off of
War for a variety of reasons that you
know when Donald Trump came out and said
he was talking about selling weapons to
the Saudis he said it's going to be
fantastic all this money is going to be
great for our economy yup it is yeah
it's money coming it's it's oil so
that's basically what's happening we do
a weapons deal with Saudi Arabia we say
we've got all these weapons we're going
to sell you you give us money that money
we use to buy oil and oil free energy
means human beings have to do less work
greatly benefit from all of this nasty
stuff are we buying the oil from the
Saudis it's a it's a global market so
when they give us money we can put it
into the global market buying petroleum
and stuff like that back from them and
other people well that's why I say
basically we give them weapons for oil
yeah you know and then we have the Petro
dollar which maintains a status quo but
yo the I I I I really part of me just
wants to see how these Urban liberals
react to the reality oh I've gone
through this if you exposed all humans
to all human trauma at once it would I
mean it would obliterate the human mind
uh it might turn everyone into into I'm
just organic sad given what they want
but it might not it might help us look
at that dude he's supposed he's trying
to get a heart right but he's refusing
to get vaccinated so they're not they
took him off the list yeah how's that
Universal Health Care sounding now so
these people on the left they're just
their attitude is but vaccines are good
and I'm like sure okay what happens when
the government comes and says we we want
you to undergo this you know this this
treatment otherwise you won't get your
medical treatment and something you
disagree with don't give the government
the authority to mandate that you get a
medical treatment in exchange for
life-saving treatment that's why we
always got to have private private
Health Care as an option but I'm just
saying all of these these know hippie
these leftists these liberal types
I just I long for the day they get
everything they want in a sense I really
don't because you know it would be chaos
and everything would fall apart but for
them to just have that that moment where
they go
oh now I get it and then just to have
that that that loss wash over them where
all of a sudden they can't eat they're
struggling to live electricity is
through the roof these people you know
I've I've found an interesting
correlation between people who are
socialist and uh uh interesting overlap
between people who are socialists and
people who have never been to a
socialist country yeah you know it seems
to be the same group of people oh my
gosh going to Chile completely changed
my world view about policing and about
socialization of police like they have
just National Police it's completely
socialized uh it was terrifying because
you'd see feds on every street corner
you'd see just feds standing there with
their guns and their in their uniforms
and it's like there's no one to protect
you from the feds at that point so you
got to kind of
de-socialize law enforcement I mean we
have a sort of interwoven socialized
system of layer layered socialism system
of socialism so it's it's a little more
I'm less like blanket socialism yeah or
if you go to like other countries like
Cuba or countries you know former Soviet
satellite right countries satellite
republics I guess it was called and the
people that come to America you know or
again Cubans Venezuelans
they know their stuff you know they talk
about love of freedom and the
Constitution and you know all the ideals
that the left hates I mean
I mean they're so I mean they they know
well another thing they say is that you
can't lose the us because this is the
last place in the world like this and I
was going to say too that with a
monoclonal antibodies things one of the
things that they're saying when Gen saki
was asked about it she was like oh well
it's because vaccines work so you're
telling me that um if you don't get a
vaccine you also have monoclonal
antibody that really sounds kind of
punitive to me but that's what happens
when you give the federal government
that kind of power that's not something
we should be trying to do at what level
well let's take a uh we'll take a poll
of the uh our friends here at the crew
and the IRL studio
um if you were to show your average
Urban liberal
everything that was supporting their way
of life
from war exploitation to experimentation
my opinion is that they would gladly
accept it if you went to them and said
here's how many kids were killed by
Obama for you to get that you know cheap
computer they'd be like agreed I'm happy
with that do you how do you guys agree
with that 100 right I think they would
especially the urban Elites in the
Washington area you look at the the
wealth concentrated in DC that continued
during the recession of 2008-2009 that
continued with covid
um the growth in defense contractors uh
over the many decades that are all based
in the Washington DC area
um you know I you can go on and on and
on and I truly think that's something
I've learned from living here in the
you're living in the DC area the last
eight years that it's it's I I I I have
you know I become more jaded but it but
I have that yeah they won't accept it
here's my question for uh these Democrat
voters
when they say you know I'm voting
Democrat for this reason right they want
to tax the rich okay here's my question
how many children are you willing to
kill in order to get higher taxes on the
rich is it one oh two three just give me
a number because Obama killed a bunch of
kids yeah Obama killed an American
citizen named Abdul Rahman al-alaki in a
drone strike on a civilian restaurant I
think it killed other people too and the
response the official response was oops
we were trying to get somebody else when
we had that in Afghanistan we I mean not
an American citizen but we had that in
Afghanistan with a drone strike and the
New York Times released this huge report
and it's like okay yeah like how many
kids are are you willing to have killed
for you is another way to phrase it and
then they might not say a lot they might
be like oh I don't want to have any kids
how many kids with parents who hate your
freedom are you willing to have killed
oh well now if they hate my freedom
that's dangerous now look look they're
gonna be okay with the numbers people
are okay with numbers I can deal with X
and Y but if you show them the image of
the person being killed it changes them
yes and this is because of the concept
of bloody hands at arm's length if it's
out of sight it's out of mind if you
don't have to see it you don't see the
bombing in Syria it doesn't bother you
it doesn't bother you if people are
jumping out of Windows in China and I
would just add I think I think that my
point especially true with people in
Washington I think
you go to some liberals in other parts
of the country
um outside of maybe LA and maybe New
York City or Chicago I I you could
probably change the minds but uh in
terms of the ruling Elites it's hard
it'd be hard to change that you get a
bunch of people in public and you walk
up to them and ask them
all of the benefits you receive with
cheap gas cheap products
international travel a strong passport
come at the expense of children dying
how many children are you willing to
have killed in your name to live this
way in public they're going to be like
oh that's really terrible and none of us
agree with that but if you get someone
truly honestly in private and it's most
I think honestly most people would be
like I don't want to have my TV shut off
I I I I like all of the the Privileges
and benefits that are afforded me if you
explain to people that slavery still
exists today that people who make your
clothing and make your phones are
effectively slaves they'd shut up I
don't want to hear it that's why when
the crit when the when the conservatives
criticized the left over having
smartphones they run into you know they
go full speed in defense mode of putting
up these silly Comics that one where
that guy is like you know there's a guy
peasant who says Society is you know
sucks and we should improve it and then
the guy pops out of the well going yet
you participate in society because
they're very very desperate to to
whitewash The Narrative and be like
we're good people we're we're good
people we're gonna be yo I acknowledge
it I know full well these computers
sitting these these monitor screens my
phone sitting in front of me yes slave
labor I'm not a big fan of it I'm not a
big fan of it but I recognize and I'll
be fully honest about how the world
works and understand the Privileges and
the benefits of everything we get cheap
gasoline the energy we use for our
machines the energies that comes from
from oil from around the world and under
Trump from this country the natural the
the fossil fuels but there are a lot of
people who want to lie because they want
to pretend to be good people they want
to act like they're opposed to this but
they will vote for it every chance they
get you go to them in private and say
Barack Obama killed kids and signed the
indefinite detention provision we're
you're gonna you're gonna sign this
you're gonna sign away your rights and
you are going to get a dollar
cheeseburger for the next 10 years
they're going to be like sign me up my
problem is knowing that this is all
built on slaves even the plastic for
this awesome comic book like
how how do I stop acknowledging that how
do I stop myself from hating myself and
want to destroy myself
you just realize the world is what it is
now now I think it's fair to say
you know we actively speak out against
it we challenge it and we try to avoid a
lot of that stuff some of it is
seemingly unavoidable if you want to
operate in the system and I'm not going
and I'm not going to pretend like it's
not true when I when I A friend of mine
who's an activist I I said you know I
was talking about this friend of mine
I was like you you claim to be on the
left and you care about you know
fighting for these causes but the
reality is you're only fighting for your
community for your country and they said
that's not true I'm fighting for
everybody I said no you're not you've
got a Samsung laptop it's made the
Foxconn Laboratories those people are
walking off the roof in Mass to commit
suicide they put up suicide nights to
catch them because their lives are
miserable you don't care about those
people you're putting money into that
you're supporting that system
they want to believe that they're good
people fighting the good fight but the
reality of the world is that most people
can't see that far most people don't
realize all the pain and suffering that
goes into everything they have
I get it I don't like it I'll try to
avoid it I try you know to you know
products made in America by good you
know free and Fair Labor and everything
like that but yo we don't make stuff in
this country anymore which is why one of
the reasons I voted for Trump in 2020
was because I would rather have a a
shirt cost 20 bucks that I can only own
a few of if it's made by someone who
gets an honest living as opposed to
helping having these these Sweatshop
factories overseas where we exploit
cheap labor when they don't get health
care or anything like that I'm not I'm
not in favor of that I'd like the world
the world to be a better place but I
tell you I would I I rest assured the
average person and most people living in
cities would sign the dotted line and
sign that deal with the devil to get
cheap crap because they don't want to
have to do the work to get it and it's
and it's exploitative but they're for it
and they want to pretend they're opposed
to it but they support it every chance I
don't know have we ever had a not not a
slave Capital slave Capital Society we
had the Romans then we had the Middle
Ages where it was all serfdom in slavery
we have not and this is an interesting
point because there has always been
slavery in the world and people tend to
try to tie it to America which is
incredibly unfair because we did not
start it we ended it we did end it and
one of the things that you guys should
do because I know this is depressing is
go to humanprogress.org because I know
the world looks bleak sometimes but it
is very much better for more people than
it has ever been good for before we are
reducing poverty at an incredible rate
people have more fresh water we have
lower infant mortality rates and even
though people aren't like actually
reproducing as much as they should be to
keep Humanity going there are at least
other things that are making life better
forever that's most people yeah let's
get the conversation up a notch let's
say you get a president who's like we're
going to go to war in the Middle East
we're going to fight for the cutter
turkey pipeline we're going to start a
war in Ukraine to push back Russia and
if you don't vote for that you get
someone who's a nice isolationist China
takes over and they kill substantially
more people so the question isn't even
how many people are you willing to
sacrifice the question is people will
die no matter what and it's a very very
complicated and difficult problem we
faces humans it's part of why it's been
offensive Wars like the history you
attack so that you don't get attacked
and it's always that's the cycle if we
if the United States pulls back from the
world stage and rescinds the American
Empire that Gap will be filled by
someone and so you end up with these
neocons these warhawks who are alike I'd
rather it be me than someone else I can
certainly understand that world view I
just don't I don't believe in that kind
of philosophical uh moral position of
it's better that I'm subjecting people
to pain and suffering because someone
else would do it anyway I'm like well
you're committing an immoral act we
should push back against the immoral
acts but not commit them it's tough man
that's uncomfortable it's an
uncomfortable conversation and I'll just
point out you know and you know beyond
products the two of the biggest events
in the world uh this year the Olympics
in China and the World Cup at the end of
the year and Qatar
all produced by slave labor yep
that you know around Thanksgiving
Christmas time everybody's gonna be
tuning in for soccer and that's been one
of the huge stories but people are still
going to tune in you know
there's I the reason I say it's mostly
City people is because people who live
out in the middle of nowhere you know
conservative types and Rural types
believe in personal responsibility are
responsible for a lot of their own food
and they're willing to roll up their
sleeves and do do hard work but people
in cities man they just want to exploit
extract not every single person just a
lot of them you know think about the
person who works at BuzzFeed right how
much how much do they pay people at
BuzzFeed 50 to 90k if you look at
glassdoor.com and what's their job to
write garbage poisonous trash BuzzFeed
is complete garbage and they're not the
only ones there's right wing garbage too
don't get me wrong uh the issue is
there's no reason in any sane reality
that someone at BuzzFeed should be
making that much money because there are
people who drive buses who deserve more
than that because driving a bus does
something for society but writing about
Brad Pitt's junk does not and they make
tons of cash all of these big New York
media companies are garbage and it's an
example of these people who are who are
providing nothing but they're extracting
everything yeah writing about I don't I
don't know some model you know or the
latest I don't know Britney Spears
videos or I went to bus with Britney's
faces at the top yeah Britney Spears
Britney Spears okay it's fine you know
that's Entertainment Tonight You know
the magazines you read at the checkout
at the grocery store but like seriously
uh to think that those organizations
make the money that they do is just
simply astounding and of course as you
remember BuzzFeed you know a combination
with all their listicles and talking
about you know this person's junk or you
know this person's hairdo they're the
ones that partnered with you know John
Brennan and Clapper and Jake Tapper to
release the Steele dossier because they
just want to extract they're stealing
the find China from the ship after the
iceberg was hit they know it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time